สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาติห้องเรียน
comprehensible  Thai ค่ะแล้วก็วันนี้มา
พบกับครูปุ๊กครูชิเช่นเคยค่ะนะในวันนี้
วันอะไรคะูชิวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศเท่าไหร่คะพุธศักราช
2567 อ่าปีค.ศเท่าไหร่คะคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะอ่าก็เหมือนเช่นเคยนะที่เรามา
เจอกันนะวันนี้ก็จะเป็นวันอังคารวันที่ 6
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 นะคะอือฮึวันนี้เรามาเจอกันแล้ว
เนี่ยครูปุ๊กเดือนเนี้ยกุมภาพันธ์แล้วไง
ปีใหม่ผ่านมา 1 เดือนแล้วหลายๆคนก็อยากจะ
รู้ไงว่าปีเนี้ยคนไทยจะชอบนะพอปีใหม่
เนี่ยก็อยากรู้ว่าปีเนี้ย
จะทำธุรกิจดีหรือไม่ดีหรือปีเนี้ยบางคนก็
คิดนะเอ๊ะปีเนี้ยฉันจะเจอคู่มั้ยเราบอก
เนื้อคู่ใช่มั้ยคนที่จะแบบปิ๊งๆแล้วก็มา
แต่งงานกันใช่มยอ่าก็เลยเรียกว่าเนื้อคู่
อ่าหรือบางคนก็อยากรู้เรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
ความ
รักนะคะความรักแต่ไม่ใช่รักคู่รักอะไรคือ
ความรักทั่วๆไปที่แบบว่าอาจจะได้โชคดี
แต่งงานหรือไม่ได้แต่งงานนะคะได้แต่งงาน
นี้รือเปล่าอ่าหรือมากๆก็บางคนอาจจะพอ
แต่งงานก็อยากมีลูกเก็อยากรู้ว่าปีเนี้ย
จะมีลูกมยจะมีลูกได้มยหรือว่าบางคนก็อาจ
จะดูเรื่องงานเป็นหลักเนาะงานเนี่ยเป็น
เรื่องสำคัญเพราะว่าเราจะมีเงินหรือไม่มี
เงินเนี่ยก็เป็นเพราะงานใช่มยงานที่เราทำ
อยู่ดีไม่ดีหรือว่ามันจะเจอปัญหาอะไรใน
ชีวิตมยเออหรือบางคนมีเงินอยากจะลงทุนแต่
ก็คือแน่ใจว่าธุรกิจที่จะเปิดเนี่ยดีแต่
มันก็ 50  50 อ่ะกลัวๆกล้าๆกล้าๆกลัวๆว่า
ทำไปแล้วเนี่ยเงินที่เก็บไว้เนี่ยมันจะ
หมดไปหรือว่ามันจะดีขึ้นอ่ะแน่นอนเนาะ
เพราะว่าหลายๆคนตั้งแต่โควิดมาเนี่ย
บริษัทอาจจะปิดค่ะแล้วก็อาจจะมีเงินที่
ได้จากบริษัทมาเค้าเรียกว่าก้อนนึงไม่รู้
จำนวนเงินเท่าไหร่เนาะแล้วก็ต้องคิดว่า
เงินอันเนี้ยถ้าเราไม่ทำงานเนี่ยใช้ไป
เรื่อยๆมันก็จะหมดใช่มั้ยคะนะใช่แต่ถ้า
เราเอามาทำธุรกิจหรือเอามาลงทุนนะเปิด
ร้านขายของก็ได้หรือทำธุรกิจอะไรดีนะก็
อ่าบางคนก็อาจจะทำสปาเอ้อเพราะว่าคนไทย
เนี่ยนะมีฝีมือเรื่องการนวดอ่าใช่มยนะก็
อาจจะทำเปิดร้านสปาดีมั้ยหรือเปิดร้าน
อาหารเปิดธุรกิจอย่างอื่นไม่รู้อะไรซ่อม
รถทำรถอะไรแบบนี้นะก็หรือบิวตี้ซาลอนหมา
แมวตัดขนอ่ะอันนี้ก็ดีนะเพราะว่าเค้าบอก
ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยคนไทยหรือว่าคนตทุกๆประเทศ
เนาะไม่อยากมีลูกแล้วเพราะว่ามีลูกเนี่ย
ค่าใช้จ่ายเยอะนะเกิดมาก็ต้องใช้แพมเพอร์
ต้องมีนมต้องมีอะไรเยอะแยะพอโตขึ้นก็ต้อง
ไปโรงเรียนต้องมีค่าใช้จ่ายเยอะแยะไปหมด
เลยบางคนก็เลยบอกว่าไม่มีดีกว่ามีหมาเป็น
ลูกแทนใช่มีหมามีแมวเป็นลูกนะก็มีค่าใช้
จ่ายนะจ่ายเงินสำหรับอาหารจ่ายเงินสำหรับ
บางคนอาจจะใส่เสื้อผ้าให้ก็แล้วแต่แต่ว่า
มันก็ไม่ได้เยอะเท่ากับเด็กใช่มั้ยคนนะคน
ๆนึงเต้องไปโรงเรียนถ้าเรียนโรงเรียนแบบ
อินเตอร์ก็โอ้โหแพงมากอเขาก็เลยนิยม
เลี้ยงหมาเลี้ยงแมวเป็นลูกค่ะูชิเอเออค
เนี้ยคนไทยเราเนี่ยเราดูหมอใช่มั้ยหรือ
เราดูดวงไม่เราเรียกว่าดูหมอหรือดูดวง
อ่ะดูหมอนี่ต้องไปโรงพยาบาลมั้ยคะอันนั้น
อันนั้นคุณหมอพยาบาลนะอันอันนั้นไปดูจริง
ๆนะหมอหล่อมั้ยเอ้ยไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่แบบนั้นุ
หมายถึงว่าเราเราจะเรียกคนที่มีความชำนาญ
หลายๆอย่างว่าหมอไงอืใช่มั้ยเช่นเช่นเก่ง
ในเรื่องนวดเราก็เรียกว่าหมอนวด
อ่าเก่งในเรื่องอะไรอ่ะเก่งในเรื่องจับผี
เราก็เรียกว่าหมอผีอ๋ออ่ะไม่ใช่รักษาผีผี
ไม่
สบายไม่ใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นน่ะเก่งในเรื่อง
ของการดูดวงว่าโชคดีหรือโชคไม่ดีเราก็บอก
เป็นหมอดูดูอนาคตไงอ่านะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
เป็นอาชีพอาชีพก็มีหลายอาชีพเหมือนกัน
เนาะที่ไม่ต้องไปเรียนที่
มหาวิทยาลัยแต่เรียกว่าหมอเหมือนกันอย่าง
เช่นนวดใช่มั้ยนวดไทยเนี่ยก็ไม่ต้องไป
มหาวิทยาลัยนะเราอาจจะไปเรียนตามที่ต่างๆ
ที่เขาเปิดนะสอนนวดเราก็นวดพอนวดเป็นเรา
ก็เรียกว่าหมอนวดละอื้อหือเห็นมเออเห็น
มั้แต่ว่าหมอดูเนี่ยเค้าก็หมายถึงคนที่ทำ
อาชีพ
นะดูหมอ
อ่ะหมอดูกับดวง
ดงดูดวงหมายถึงเ้าบอกว่าคนที่เกิดมาเนี่ย
เหมือนเหมมีดวงดาวนะใช่ค่ะอืเบอกว่าเวลา
เกิดเนี่ยมันจะมีดวงดาวดวงดาวก็อาจจะเป็น
แบบดวงอาทิตย์ใช่มยพระอาทิตย์แล้วก็จะมี
ดาวพุทธดาวศุกดาวโลกดาวอังคารดาวอนะมีดาว
ดาว
ไถดาวลูก
ไก่ดาวลูกไก่มี 7
ดวงเห็นมยก็อันนี้เราก็บอกว่าเป็นดวงดาว
แล้วเวลาเวลาเราเกิดเนี่ยเขาบอกว่ามัน
เป็นความมีความสัมพันธ์หรือเกี่ยวกัน
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยคนที่เกิดในช่วงเวลาวัน
ก่อนวันเดือนปีเวลาเกิดเนี่ย
สำคัเกิดมาแล้วเนี่ยจะดีหรือไม่ดีแต่ก็
ไม่มีใครดีแบบดีๆๆๆๆๆๆ 100% มันก็จะมีบาง
ปีดีมากบางปีอาจจะดีนิดหน่อยบางปีอาจจะ
ไม่ดีเลยก็มีแล้วแต่อ่าเพราะดวงมัน
เปลี่ยนใช่มั้ยใช่ดวงมันเปลี่ยนไปตามเวลา
นะเราอาจจะไปอยู่ในตรงที่เราไม่แข็งแรง
กำลังอ่อนนะคะเอ่อช่วงช่วงปีนั้นเราก็อาจ
จะทำธุรกิจแล้วก็ไม่ประสบความสำเร็จนะ
ธุรกิจอาจจะตกนะช่วงโควิดใช่นะก็เหมือน
เหมือนมีเพื่อนน่ะมาดูว่าเออตอนช่วงก่อน
โควิดนะเพื่อนบอกว่าจะลงทุนเนี่ยเอ่อติด
ต่อซื้อของจากประเทศจีนมาขายดีมั้ยนะอืพอ
ดูโอ้ไม่ดีนะเอออ้าครูปุ๊กเป็นเป็นหมอดู
เหรอคะใช่ค่ะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเรียนมาค่ะโอ้โห
ครูปุ๊กเป็นหมอดูอะไรคะครูปุ๊กจะดูวัน
เดือนปีเกิด
ออเหมือนๆเป็นโหราศาสตร์แบบนั้นเหรอ
โหราศาสตร์มันจะลึกกว่าละเอียดกว่า
โหราศาสตร์เนี่ยโอ้โหมัน
จะมันจะเก่งมากต้องคนที่เรียนแบบเรียน
จริงจังอค่ะคูชิอ้าอันนี้ยากเหรอคะอเ
เนี่ยๆอันเนี้ยอันนี้คือโหราศาสตร์มั้ย
ใช่อันเนี้ยจะยากมากไม่ใช่ยากธรรมดาค่ะ
ยากมากๆอ๋ออันนี้มีเดือนด้วยนะมีนาค
กุมภาพันธ์มกราคมเ้าทำไมเดือนมันไม่เรียง
กันค่ะอ๋อมันไม่เรียงค่ะเพราะว่าทิศของ
แต่ละอันมันไม่เหมือนกันอ่ามันไม่ได้ไล่
แบบอาทิตย์จันทร์อังคารพุธพฤหัสศุกร์
เสาร์อาทิตย์อย่างงี้ด้วยมันก็ไม่เรียง
แบบนี้ด้วยค่ะนะเพราะว่าแต่ละวันมันจะตรง
กับทิศที่ไม่เหมือนกันเค้าจะอยู่ตามทิศนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยอันนี้เลขต่างๆเนี่ยก็
คือหมายถึงมีมีถึงเลข 7 เอ้ยมีถึงเลข 8
ด้วยอันนี้วันเกิดเหรอก็คือถ้าถ้าวัน 7
วันไงครูชิใน 7 วันก็คืออาทิตย์จันทร์
อังคารพุธพฤหัสบศุกร์เสาร์ใช่มั้ยมี 7
แต่พุธเนี่ยเขาจะแบ่งครึ่งก็คือพุธกลาง
วันกับพุธกลางคืนพุธกลางคืนก็จะเป็นเลข 8
โอ๊ยปวด
หัวอันนี้เนี่ยจะปวดหัวกว่านั้นอีกคุณูชิ
เรียนอันนี้ยากยากบอกเลยว่ายากมากแต่ถาม
ว่าเวลาดูแล้วเนี่ยโอ้โหูบุ๊กนะให้คะแนน
ถ้าคนที่เก่งๆนะเต็มเลยคะแนนเต็มรหมายถึง
ว่าดูแล้วมันตรงใช่นะบอกว่าอย่าทำธุรกิจ
ถ้าทำแล้วจะธุรกิจล้มแน่ๆก็จะล้มจริงๆ
จริงมันชัดเจนใช่ถ้าบอกว่าได้เงินคือได้
เงิน
เดือนไหนวันไหนแบบอันนี้ละเอียดถึงขนาด
แบบคุณสามารถจะรู้ได้ด้วยว่าวันไหนโอ้โห
อันนี้แบบเป็นเป็นโหราศาสตร์นะเกี่ยวกับ
ดวงดาวเกี่ยวกับวันเดือนปีเกิดอ๋ออันนี้
ครูปุ๊กก็เรียนมาเหมือนกันโอ้ยอันนี้ไม่
ได้ค่ะยากเกินไปอ้าแล้ววันเดือนปีเกิดที่
ครูปุ๊กเรียนคืออะไรอ่ะครูปุ๊กจะเรียน
เป็นแบบเลข 7 ตัวแต่ว่าก็เป็น 4 ฐานแบบ
นี้ค่ะเอาวันเดือนปีใช่มยวันอย่างอันนี้
เค้าเกิดวันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์ก็จะเลข 6
ขึ้นก่อนแล้วก็ไล่ไป 6  7 แล้วก็ 1  2  3
4  5 แบบนี้ค่ะนะอ่าแล้วก็ถ้าเดือนใช่มย
เดือนที่ 7 ก็เลข 7 ขึ้นก่อน 7 แต่เจะได้
แค่ 7 ค่ะเดือนที่ 8 ก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็นเลข 1
ออนะ 2  3  4  5  6 แล้วก็ 7 อย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะอื 8  9  10  11  12 เราก็จะไล่ไล่ไล่
ไล่ตัวเลขเนาะแต่ว่าเวลาดูเดือนมันมันก็
ยากกว่ามันยากที่จะอธิบายให้จบภายในครึ่ง
ชั่วโมงค่ะูชินะแล้วเค้าก็จะเอาปีใช่มั้ย
วันเดือนปีเกิดปีเกิดเนี่ยเราจะนับเป็น 12
นักสัตว์ค่ะนะปีหนูนักเรียนน่าจะรู้จัก
เนาะเพราะว่าแบบคนเอเซียเนี่ยจะเหมือนๆ
กันนะจะดูเป็นปีเกิดเป็นปีแบบปีสัตว์นะ
หนูวัวเสือกระต่ายมังกรตอนเนี้ยเป็นมังกร
ใช่มั้ยเป็นงูคนไทยจะเรียกงูใหญ่อแล้วปี
หน้าก็จะเป็นงูเล็กนะก็ไล่ไปค่ะมีสัตว์ 12
อย่างนะอ้าจะไล่ตัวเลขก็คือถ้าเลข 3 ก็
หนูวัวเสือใช่มั้ยที่ครูบุ๊กให้เริ่มดู
อันแรกก็คืออาจจะเกิดปีเสือเลข 3 ใช่มั้ย
อืชั่วูขานเถาะมาะโลงมาะเส็งมาะเมียมาแม
ก็นะแพะก็ขึ้นเป็นเลข 1 ใหม่มันไม่มีเลข 8
ค่ะคือสัตว์ตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยคะ 12 ตัวูชิ
เกิดปีกระต่ายใช่ค่ะใช่เพราะฉะนั้นครููชิ
ก็จะเป็นเลข 4 ค่ะอ๋อครูชิต้องเริ่มต้ 2
3  4 ใช่ 5  6  7  8  8 ไม่มีใช่มยก็
เป็นเลข 1 ค่ะอ่าอันนี้ก็จะเป็น 1  2  3
4  5 แล้วก็มา 1 ใหค่ะคือถ้าเป็นหนูก็จะ
เลข 1 นะเป็นแพะก็เป็นเลข
1 โอ้โหอันนี้ต้องเรียนเนาใช่ๆแต่คนคน
ที่ดูดูดวงเนี่ยก็ต้องเรียนใช่มั้ยใช่
แล้วก็นอกจากเรียนอันนี้แล้วก็เอาวัน
เดือนปีเกิดมารวมกันได้เลขอะไรเนี่ยเลข
นี้ก็สำคัญค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยต้องไป
ศึกษาเรื่องเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขต้องไปเรียน
เกี่ยวกับตัวเลขนะคนที่เรียนก็จะเข้าใจนะ
ว่าตัวเลขเนี่ยอย่างเลข 16 เนี่ยหมายถึง
เค้าเรียกว่าโสรสมหามงคลคือถ้าปีไหนมาตรง
กับเลขนี้เนี่ยโอ้ปีนั้นคุณโชคดีมากๆ
เกี่ยวกับเงินอือืโอ๊แสดงว่าเอ่อการดูดวง
เนี่ยของคนไทยเนี่ยมีดูเยอะนะโอหเยอะมาก
ค่ะครูชิอย่างอย่าอย่างอันเนี้ยครูชิเคย
เห็นเค้าเรียกดูกราฟใช่มั้ยดูกฟอันนี้ก็
จะเอาวันวันอาทิตย์วันจันทร์วันอังคารวัน
พุธวันเกิดเดือนเกิดนะคะมกราคกุมภาพันธ์
มีนาคเมษายนนะคะแล้วก็ปีปีเกิดน่าจะเป็น
ปีแบบที่ครููปุ๊กนับอ่ะนะชั่วฉลูขานเถาะ
มะโลงมาเสงนะคะนะนักเรียนบอกเอ้ยทำไมนับ
ไม่เหมือนกันไม่ใช่หนูวัวเสือกระต่ายเหรอ
เค้ามีเรียกอีกแบบนึงค่ะมีชื่อมีชื่อมี
ชื่อ
นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยอย่างอย่างของกูชิ
เนี่ยถ้าเกิดเป็นเป็นอันเนี้ยมันก็จะนับ
วันอาทิตย์ใช่มั้ยวันอาทิตย์ก็จะเป็น 1
ถูกมั้ย
อืเขาก็จะมีแบบเนาะมีแบบเริ่มต้น 1  2  3
4  5  6  7  7 วันเพราะครูชิเริ่มวัน
อาทิตย์ใช่มยใช่เสร็จแล้วเดือนูชิเดือน
เดือนมิถุนายนก็เป็นเดือน 6 นะ 7  8  9
10  11  12  1  2  3  4  5 เสร็จแล้วครู
ชิปีเาะปีที่ 4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11
12  1  2  3 แล้วก็เอามาบวกกันนะใช่ๆแต่
ว่าถ้าเลขไหนเกิน 7 น่ะเขาจะเป็น
เริ่มลบด้วยเลข 7 ค่ะลบด้วยเลข 7 แล้ว
เหลือเท่าไหร่มันก็จะเป็นเลขนั้นอย่าง
เช่นเลข 8 เกิน 7 ลบด้วย 7 ก็จะเหลือเป็น
เลข 1 ก็คือจะเป็นเลขเริ่มใหม่เป็นเลขเลข
1  2 อ้าอันนี้รวมกันไม่ใช่ 11 นะรอัน
นั้นน่ะถูกค่ะได้ 11
ค่ะอันนี้ก็ได้
14 แต่กูชิคะมันจะดูไม่เหมือนกันเพราะ
ว่าของกูชิอ่ะเดือนกูชิที่เกิดน่ะไม่ใช่
เดือน 6 ค่ะมันจะเป็นเดือน 7 แล้วเพราะ
ว่าเดือนแบบอ๋อโอเคเอาเอาเป็นแบบสมมุติ
แล้วก็มาบวกใช่มยแล้วก็เป็นตัวเลขแบบ
เนี้ยอะไรที่เกิน 12 เนี่ยอันนี้ 14 เกิน
12 ก็กลายเป็น 2 แบบนี้เสร็จแล้วก็มา
มาร์ค 11 อืใช่มั้ย 2 แล้วก็มาร์คไปแบบ
นี้แล้วก็เป็นกราฟขึ้นมาแบบนี้นะอือฮึอ่า
ก็จะเหมือนกับที่กูชิโชว์ให้ดูเมื่อกี้
ใช่มยแบบนี้ก็มีคนดูเยอะใช่
มยแล้วก็จะรู้ด้วยนะว่าอันเนี้ยตอนอายุ
19 อายุ 19
เนี่ยจะเป็นเรื่องคู่ครองโอ้โหคู่ครองจะ
มาจะมาตอนอายุ 19 นะใช่มยมาจากญาติเหรอคะ
ญาติแนะนำเออเป็นไปได้ค่ะอาจจะเป็นญาติ
อ่ามีญาติมาแนะนำให้รู้จักเป็นเพื่อนของ
ญาติเป็นอะไรกับญาติเนี่ยนะค่ะเออแบบ
เนี้ยเนาะก็จะมีคนที่แบบสามารถดูได้หรือ
เรื่องนี่ปีนี้ปีนี้อายุ 22 การงานนี่ดี
มากมากโอ้โหสูงมาก 100% เลยนะชโชคดี
เกี่ยวกับงานอืปี 64 นะอายุ 22 ปีโอ้โห
แบบนี้นะแล้วก็มีช่วงที่แบบดวงไม่ดีนะ
อายุ 14 เนี่ดวงไม่ดีเป็นเรื่องกับ
ทรัพย์เสียเงินคนายเสียเงินหมดตัวใช่ก็
คืออาจจะมีคดีความก็ได้ใช่มั้ยอาจจะตำรวจ
จับอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเยหรือโดนฟ้องนะเป็น
Blacklist หรืออะไรแบบเนี้ยนะเห็นมั้ย
เค้าปี 62 ใช่มั้ยเสร็จแล้วปี 63 เนี่ยตก
ลงมาเลยกราฟอายุ 23 เนี่ยตกลงมาเลย 63
เนี่ยเริ่มโควิด
เออ
นะเค้ารู้ได้ยังไงว่าจะมี
โควิดดวงไงดวงแต่ละคนไงคะถ้าถ้าปีเนี้ย
ถ้าลงแบบเนี้ยก็คือไม่ควรจะเริ่มทำธุรกิจ
อะไรเลยอพอรู้ว่าดวงตัวเองเป็นแบบนี้
เนี่ยดวงเนี่ยตกเค้าเรียกดวงตกเนก็คือไม่
ต้องทำธุรกิจค่ะเพราะว่าทำไปมีแต่เสีย
เงินไม่มีได้เงินคืนค่ะอืนะก็คือเราก็มา
ดูแบบเนี้ยค่ะนะแล้วนอกจากดูกราฟแล้วเรา
มีการดูดวงแบบไหนอีกคะออดูมือดูลายมือค่ะ
เส้นลายมือนะนะนักเรียนบอกโอ๊ย 3 เส้น
เนี่ยมันอะไรโหมันไม่ใช่แค่ 3 เส้นค่ะ
เออูมีมีค่ะมีคนขายหนังสือนี่ขายหนังสือ
เกี่ยวกับดูลายมือ
ค่ะเยอะค่ะนะดูลายมือเนี่ยเคต้องพิมพ์มือ
ออกมาด้วยก็คือเขาจะมีสีดำทาใช่มยแล้วก็
แปะลงไปในกระดาษเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันจะ
เห็นเส้นเล็กๆถ้านักเรียนเห็นเนี่ยเราจะ
มีเส้นเยอะแยะไปหมดเนอะเส้นเล็กเส้นน้อย
เนี่ยมันจะมองเห็นมีความหมายหมดเลยเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะจะเล็กนิดหน่อยนะมันก็เป็นความหมาย
ได้หมดครูปุ๊ก็อ้าครูชินึกว่าดูแต่เส้น
ที่มันใหญ่ๆเนี่ยชัดๆนะอันนี้น่ะดูใน
เรื่องธรรมดาค่ะเป็นลักษณะนิสัยคนดูจาก 3
เส้นนี้ได้แล้วก็โรคภัยไข้เจ็บอื้อหือนะ
มีุปุก็ดูหมอนหมอดูลายมือเป็นเหรอคะก็พอ
นิดหน่อยค่ะได้นิดหน่อย
อ่าอันนี้ครูก็ต้องไปเรียนเหมือนกันใช่ม
แพงมใช่ก็แพงนะครูชินะูกเรียนเนี่ยขอโทษ
นะคะเสียตังค์เท่าไหร่โอ้โหมันเสียไม่ใช่
แค่ค่าสมัครเนี่ย 3 คอร์สนะมันก็เป็น
หมื่นนะครูชิ 3 คอร์สเพราะว่ามันจะมีแบบ
เรียนเกี่ยวกับเส้นลายมือเรียนกับเกี่ยว
กับเทคนิคการพิมพ์มือวัดมือใช่ไหมวัดก็
คือเอาเอาไม้บรรทัดแล้วก็เช็คว่าเส้นนี้
เส้นนี้เท่าไหร่อายุ 28 อยู่ตรงไหนอันนี้
ก็ 1 คอร์สสำหรับการพิมพ์มือวัดมือพิมพ์
มือแล้วก็อีกคอร์สนึงก็จะเป็นตัวเลขที่
ครูบุ๊กให้ดูอ่ะ 7 ตัว 4 ฐานนะก็แล้วก็เ
จะมาดูร่วมกันมันจะทำให้
เข้าใจมากขึ้นโอเคเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยคนที่
ดูดวงสามารถดูจากลายเส้นของมือได้ใช่แต่
แต่คูชิเห็นหนังสือที่ขายเนี่ยมีนอกจาก
ลายมือแล้วอ่ะเค้ามีลายเท้าด้วยเหรอคะเออ
มีคนเรียนใช่มีคนเรียนค่ะแต่ว่าน้อยกว่า
หลายมือค่ะเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยเราปกติเรา
ไม่ค่อยชอบชอบเอาเท้าดูเท้าอยู่แล้วเนาะ
นะจะมีน้อยคนที่ดูค่ะแต่บางคนที่เค้า
เรียนเนี่ยเค้าก็บอกว่ามันชัดมากอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยมันจะชัดมากกว่าเส้นลายมืออะไร
อย่างงีู้ปุ๊กก็ไม่รู้นะไม่เคยเรียนลายาม
ไม่เคยเรียนดูลายเท้าค่ะนะ
อ่ามีอีกอันค่ะที่ครูชิเห็นว่าคนก็นิยมดู
ดวงดูหมอแบบเอ่อดูจากลักษณะรูปหน้าเราที่
เขาเรียกว่าโหงเฮ้ง
โงแปลว่า 5 ใช่มั้ยเจหนโหหนอซา 4 หู
นะคะดูอะไรคะคิ้วตา 3 จมูก 4 ปาก 5 หู
หรือห้าน
นะคือบางคนเขาก็ลงละเอียดก็จะเป็นแบบทั้ง
หน้าผากนะทั้งหนกแก้มอืทั้งหนกแก้มตรงนี้
นะหนกแก้มหนกแก้มคือส่วนที่สูงที่สุดตรง
นี้เนี่ย
อ่านี่กุกุกชี้หนกแก้มของตัวเองนี่ใช่มั้
ตรงที่สนี่ตรงที่มันมีกระดูกเนี่ยเ้ากู
ชี้สูงที่สุดอยู่ตรงนี้เอาตรงนี้ถ้าเราทำ
เนี่ยเราจะเห็นเราจะเช็คได้ว่าตรงไหนที่
มันมีกระดูกสูงขึ้นมาเนี่ยอันนั้นน่ะโหนก
แก้มบางคนเนี่ยแก้มเนี่ยไม่มีเนื้อเลยจะ
หอจะเห็นโหนกแก้มชัดมากแต่ถ้าเป็นแบบคน
จีนที่สัตโหงเฮ้งเนี่ยเาจะบอกว่าไม่ดี
เพราะว่าถ้าผอมไปเนี่ยไม่ดีนะก็จะดู 1
หน้าผาดใช่มั้ยดูหน้าผากดูคิ้วดูโหนกแก้ม
ด้วยอืดูคางมั้ยคะดูค่ะจริงๆถ้าถ้ารวม
ทั้งหมดนะมันอาจจะไม่ใช่โหงเฮ้งก็ได้นะดู
หรือแบ่งเป็นส่วนๆอืแบ่งเป็น 5 ส่วนส่่วน
นี้ก็คือดูหน้าผากดู
หัวตรงนี้ก็คือดูคิ้วดูตาดูดูหนกแก้มแก้ม
ดูหูดูจริงๆคนจีนน่ะดูทุกอย่างจมูกก็ดู
ใช่มยจมูกเนี่ยถ้าจมูกใหญ่จมูกมีเนื้อ
เยอะน่ะจมูกมังกรน่ะเหมือนมังกรอ่าเจะบอก
ว่าจมูก
หมูคนที่มีเนื้อจมูกเยอะอ่ะคนจริงบอกว่า
ก็อันเนี้ย
ดีแต่เราอาจจะไม่ชอบเนาะเอาเห็นคนไป
ศัลยกรรมแล้วเอาเนื้อออกใช่ๆเราไม่ชอบไง
เราอยากจมูกโด่ง
ก็บางคนเขาก็ไม่ได้สนใจเรื่องเรื่อง
สาสตร์เกี่ยวกับโหง่เฮ้งก็ได้นะก็เอาแค่
สวยขึ้นโอเคละเห็นมยบางคนต้องไปทำตาเพราะ
ว่าหางตาตกก็ไม่ดีใช่มยต้องหนักหางตาเบอก
ว่าถ้าหางตาชี้ขึ้นเนี่ยดีกว่าอ๋อเอาชกเท
แปะ
ค่ะสกเทปแปะเลยค่ะอันนี้คือโหงเฮ้งดีใช่
มันไม่ดูขี้โกงเหรอคะพอเอานักเรียนคะพอ
เราเอาอันนี้ขึ้นปุ๊บูชิเหมือนกับคนขี้
โกงเลยอ้าไม่ใช่เหรอคะอันนี้เนี่ยหางตาตก
ดูดูใจดีแต่พอขึ้นอย่างงี้ปุ๊บโอ้โหดูมา
เสียมากใช่มลักษณะคิ้วก็เหมือนกันเคิ้ว
โก่งคิ้วแล้วแบบอันเนี้ยเคจะบอกว่าอะไรนะ
เหมือนคนขี้โกงอย่างกูชิบอกอ่ะก็สาม
เหลี่ยมอันนี้ฉลาดค่ะ
อ่านักเรียนคิ้วสามเหลี่ยมนะฮะอันนี้คิ้ว
คิ้วสามเหลี่ยมนี่เป็นคิ้วฉลาดูชิจำได้
เพราะว่าพอมีไม่รู้ว่ามีใครบอกูชิอ่ะคิ้ว
สามเหลี่ยมฉลาดใช่มั้ยูชิก็เลยชอบมอง
ปรากฏว่าเจ้าสัวธานินค่ะคิ้วสามเหลี่ยม
แบบ
นี้ไม่ติดค่ะคิ้วแบบอย่างงี้เลยค่ะกูปุ๊ก
คิ้วแบบแบบเนี้ยเค้าไม่ได้เอาเอาเอามีด
กันออกไปใช่
มั้ยคิ้วเออคุณชิบอกเออคิ้วเสามเหลี่ยม
จริงๆคิ้วต้องเหมือนภูเขา
ออไม่เป็นไรค่ะเดี๋ยวเวลาครูชิไปไหนูชิจะ
วาดคิ้วเป็นคิ้วสามเหลี่ยมดูเป็นคนไอคิว
ดีและ
ฉลนะคะเอออันนี้ใช้ได้นะเอาเอาตาขึ้นด้วย
ค่ะ
เขียนอาตาขึ้นข้างบนเห็นมหลายๆคนเขาก็เลย
เวลาอายไลเนอร์ก็จะปัดหางตา
ขึ้นได้ค่ะครูปุ๊กครูชิจะมีหางตาขึ้นอื
เอาขึ้นแค่ไหน
คะอันนั้นก็มากไปแล้ว
ค่ะโอยเขียนไม่ได้
ค่ะโอหอันนี้ดูแบบคิวดีเลยเป็นผู้มีความ
รู้ดูฉลาดขึ้นมาทันทีคิ้วสาม
เหลี่ยมเห็นมแล้วก็ปากก็เหมือนกันเค้าก็
ดูลักษณะของปากอะไรอย่างเงี้ยก็อันนี้
เป็นลักษณะของแบบคนจีนที่เา้าดูเนาะโหง่
เฮ้งนะแต่ถ้าเป็นแบบต่างชาติเค้าก็จะมีดู
เป็นไพ่ทารก
ไพยิบซีคนไทยเรียกไพ่ยิบซีนะนักเรียนจะ
เรียกมีไพ่กี่ใบรู้มยเยอะนะโอ๊ครูปุ๊กมี
ด้วยโโอครูปุ๊กมีไสยศาสตร์มากเลยนะค่ะสาย
มูค่ะมีๆมีเอ่อไพ่ทาโร่มีกี่ใบคมีกี่ใบ
นักเรียน
นับอ๋อแสดงว่าครูไม่รู้มีกี่ใบน่าจะมี 6
กว่าใบอ่ะ 63 มั้งครูชีได้ยินมาแบบนั้น
ใช่มั้ยก็ไม่แน่ใจค่ะไม่แน่ใจนะคะรู้ว่า
เยอะมีหลายสบใบค่ะแต่ก็ต้องรู้หมดนะว่า
แต่ละใบมีความหมายอะไรใช่นะแต่ละใบเนี่ย
โอโหนะซึ่งมันมีรูปภาพนะบางทีเราก็เดาจาก
รูปภาพได้บ้างอนะว่าดีหรือไม่ดีนะเพราะ
ว่าถ้าแบบนี้
ก็คิดว่าดีมั้ยคะ
เอ่อมีไม้เท้าดูหน้าตาคนดูเศร้า
ๆไม่น่าดีค่ะใช่นะเหมือนเป็นทุก์นั่นแหละ
อืนะก็จะมีไพ่ที่ดีกับไพ่ที่ไม่ดีใช่มั้ย
ทุกคนก็อยากจะจับไพ่ที่ดีเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยพอปีใหม่ทีนึงเนี่ยเค้าก็ต้องหาดู
ค่ะว่าปีนี้เนี่ยเราจะดวงดีโชคดีมั้ยนะ
เราก็เลยดูจากหลายๆวิธีการดูเนาะนะโอ้ครู
ชี้เนี่ยเห็นคนไทยเนี่ยมีการดูดูหมอหรือ
ดูดวงเนี่ยเยอะนะหรือบางทีเนี่ยเราอาจจะ
เห็นว่าเค้าดูจากตัวเลขไงกูปุ๊กอือฮึนะ
เลขนะตัวเลขดูดูดูเลขเลขสุดท้ายของเบอร์
โทรศัพท์ของเลขที่บ้านของเลขที่รถอะไรแบบ
เนี้ยนะคะวันเกิดด้วยค่ะอเกิดวันอะไรวัน
ที่เท่าไหรออืโอ้โหอันนี้ก็เป็นเรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับการดูดวงเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขนะเอ้ย
แสดงว่าคนไทยดูดวงเยอะนะใช่ๆบางคนบอกไม่
ได้เชื่อนะแต่ก็ชอบ
ดูอยากรู้ไงหลายๆคนก็อยากรู้อนาคตเออเรา
ก็อยากรู้ว่ามันตรงมั้ยตรงเนี่ยเราบอกว่า
แม่นใช่มั้ยหมอดูเนี่ยแม่นมั้ยดูแม่นมย
หมอดูบอกปีนี้จะได้แต่งงานแล้วตลกละไม่
ได้แต่งหรอกยังหาแฟนไม่ได้เลยนะฮะปรากฏ
ว่าอีกวันนึงไปเดินชน
กันเกิดตกหลุมรักอืรักแรก
พบเย้พบกัน 1 อาทิตย์แต่ง
งานทำไมเร็ว
จังเอ้อเออเหนื่อยและวันเนี้ยชวนครูปุ๊ก
ดูหมอจนเหนื่อยนะเอาไว้้โอกาสมากเพราะว่า
เวลานักเรียนได้ยินคนไทยพูดว่าไปดูหมอกัน
อันนี้ไม่ใช่ไปโรงพยาบาลนะหมายถึงไปดูดวง
ไปดูไม่รู้จะอันไหนที่เราบอกไปเนาะนะก็
คือดูดวงของตัวเองว่าปีนี้โชคดีโชคไม่ดี
อ่าถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะไปแกนพาเลส
ใช่มั้ยมีมีสนามหลวงนะบางทีมีโต๊ะหมอดูดู
ด่วงนะก็นักเรียนเชื่อหรือไม่เชื่อไม่
เป็นไรนะเพราะว่าก็จะมีคนไทยเนี่ยเชื่อ
เยอะๆนะรู้รู้จักนะว่าอันนี้เราเรียกว่า
ดูดวงเป็นหมอดูค่ะดูดวงใช่นะวันนี้ก็หมด
เวลาแล้วเราก็ต้องลาทุกคนไปก่อนค่ะแล้ว
เรามาเจอกันใหม่ในคลิปต่อๆไปนะคะนะก็วัน
นี้ขอบคุณมากค่ะูชิสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ขอบคุณค่ะ